Transcription: Elisabeth Buffard
Relecteur: eric vautier
L’océan et le surf.
C’est le moyen de me déconnecter,
mais aussi de partager une passion.
Donc tous les ans, j’organise
une journée d’initiation handi-surf
avec les écoles de surf locales
et l’association nationale de Handi Surf.
Là, j’accompagne dans l’eau
Maël et d’autres,
amputés de la main,
du bras et même des jambes.
Imaginez l’organisation qu’il faut
pour les descendre sur la plage,
les accompagner dans l’eau,
et les disposer sur la planche de surf.
Imaginez-vous réussir à tenir
sur une planche de surf instable
avec un seul bras ou une seule jambe,
ou même avec une prothèse ?
Eh bien, ils y arrivent.
Et je peux vous dire
que dans ces journées, on se marre bien.
Dans l’eau, ils parlent ouvertement
et avec beaucoup d’humour,
de leur handicap et de leurs galères
de tous les jours.
Rien que de réussir à enfiler
un maillot de bain, par exemple.
Pour moi, ce sont des héros du quotidien.
Alors pourquoi je fais ça, finalement ?
Pourquoi j’accompagne Maël faire du surf ?
Parce que pour moi, passer du temps
différemment avec mes patients
est essentiel.
Oui, cet enfant est aussi mon patient
et au-delà de le soigner,
il s’agit de l’aider à repousser encore
un peu plus les limites de son corps,
l’aider à se sentir vivant
et en fait aussi à me sentir vivant.
Pour l’anecdote, Philippe Nau,
un des participants
de ces premières journées d’initiation,
et lui-même amputé de la jambe,
est devenu vice-champion du monde
de handi-surf
en Californie, quelques années après.
Une superbe victoire
pour lui et pour nous tous.
Bonsoir, je suis Edward de Keating Hart,
chirurgien de la main
et des prothèses bioniques en France
et à ce jour, avec mon équipe, nous avons
opéré trois patients amputés du bras
pour leur permettre
d’utiliser un bras bionique.
Et le dernier, tout récemment,
le 20 mars 2023.
Vous vous en doutez, mon métier
est fait de technologie de pointe,
de recherche,
mais c'est bien plus que ça.
Et je vais vous expliquer.
Déjà, qu’est-ce que la bionique ?
La bionique, c’est une discipline
qui utilise des dispositifs électroniques
pour imiter le monde vivant et notamment
le fonctionnement du cerveau.
Un sacré challenge.
Et une prothèse bionique,
alors, comment ça fonctionne ?
C’est un membre artificiel
qui va reproduire
les gestes élémentaires
d’un bras normal à l’aide d’électrodes
en reliant les muscles au cerveau
par l’intermédiaire d’une chirurgie
de greffe nerveuse appelée la TMR.
En gros, le but de cette intervention
est de diminuer les douleurs
nerveuses du patient
et de lui permettre de faire fonctionner
sa prothèse par la pensée,
le plus naturellement possible.
Presque comme vous et moi en fait.
Cette chirurgie complexe
est née aux États-Unis,
mais elle n’était pas accessible
en France,
ce qui obligeait certains de nos patients
à faire des milliers de kilomètres
pour se faire soigner.
Alors imaginez-vous
devoir traverser un océan
pour faire soigner vos hémorroïdes,
par exemple.
Aberrant, non ?
Eh bien, cette opération
a vu le jour en France
grâce à une femme
et à toute mon équipe médicale.
Je vous présente Priscille.
Je l’ai rencontrée un matin
dans le bureau de Silvio
et je m’en rappelle comme si on y était.
Silvio,
c’est l’orthoprothésiste de l’équipe.
C'est celui qui va gérer tous les réglages
de la prothèse bionique.
C'est le mécano de la bande.
À ce moment-là, je vois arriver
une femme souriante, joyeuse, élégante.
Un mélange de force ultime,
mais aussi de faiblesse assumée.
Lors de cette rencontre,
elle nous interpelle.
Elle nous appelle à l’aide dans un monde
qui ferme beaucoup trop les yeux
sur le handicap.
Et petit à petit, en se livrant,
Priscille décide de me faire confiance
et de prendre le risque
de se faire réopérer
pour bénéficier de ce type de prothèse,
et de suivre également une rééducation
longue de deux années.
Elle prend aussi le risque
que ça ne marche pas.
Beaucoup d’incertitudes,
beaucoup de doutes.
Ses nerfs vont-ils repousser ?
Son cerveau va-t-il se réveiller
suffisamment
pour faire fonctionner cette prothèse ?
Et nous ?
Est-ce qu’on sera à la hauteur ?
Mais Priscille et moi, nous sommes
tous les deux habités
par une volonté indéfectible
de vouloir toujours,
toujours aller plus loin
et de réaliser nos rêves.
Elle veut redevenir une artiste peintre.
Moi, je veux lui prouver qu’en France,
il est possible de lui réaliser
cette greffe bionique,
qu’il est possible
qu’elle reprenne ses pinceaux
et reprenne aussi goût à la vie.
Elle me dit vouloir reconquérir son corps,
arrêter de le subir.
Lorsqu’elle prononce ces phrases,
je suis bluffé.
Quel combat !
À ce moment-là,
c’est une évidence pour nous :
le courant passe.
Allez, allons, go, allons-y
pour réaliser ce projet un peu fou.
Quand j’en parle au reste de l’équipe,
de cette aventure,
tout le monde répond présent.
Et notamment deux amis chirurgiens,
un Français et un Allemand, pour rendre
ce moment encore plus solide.
C’est donc accompagné
d’amis et de confrères
que cette aventure bionique s’est rêvée,
imaginée, organisée puis concrétisée.
Et en 2018, Priscille devient
la première femme bionique de France.
Au moment même où je vous parle,
elle est composée à 30%
de composants électroniques.
Et malgré ça,
elle est plus humaine que jamais.
Sa prothèse est chiffrée à 160 000€.
Oui, ça coûte un bras.
(Rires)
Mais ce qui vaut de l’or,
ce n’est pas la prothèse,
c’est la détermination de cette femme
à soulever des montagnes
pour mener à bien
son projet de reconstruction.
Et c’est sans doute aussi pour ça
que je me suis retrouvé
avec toute l’équipe médicale
en dossard et en chaussures fluo
pour courir un dix kilomètres.
Moi qui déteste la course à pied.
Mais nous voulions absolument,
lors de cet événement,
l’aider à récolter des fonds
pour financer cette prothèse.
Car oui, cette prothèse
est très mal remboursée
par le système de santé actuel
et reste à ce jour inaccessible
pour la plupart de nos patients.
Soigner, c’est mon métier,
mais c’est pour moi beaucoup plus que ça.
On va revenir un petit peu en arrière.
Pour nous, chirurgiens, l’amputation,
c’est vécu toujours comme un échec.
C’est une décision
excessivement difficile à prendre,
mais un geste de sauvetage
pour nos patients.
Nous, sortis du bloc, notre job est fini,
mais c’est pour eux
que le plus dur reste à venir.
Et les suites sont souvent dramatiques.
Ils souffrent de deux choses,
après la perte d’une partie de leur corps.
Premièrement, des douleurs
de membre fantôme.
Ce sont des douleurs
à la limite du supportable,
les obligeant à consommer
des tonnes de médicaments.
Cette douleur, c'est la réponse du cerveau
à la disparition du membre.
Et cela se traduit par des brûlures,
des contractures,
des décharges électriques
qui sont brutales, continues,
et qui surviennent sans prévenir.
Priscille, un jour, m’a dit :
« Edward, tu sais, chez moi,
la douleur de membre fantôme,
c’est comme si j’accouchais
tous les jours pendant 12 h non-stop
et sans péridurale. »
Ici, il n’y a qu’une partie
du public qui peut comprendre.
Mais vous imaginez le niveau de douleur
que ressentent ces patients ?
Et moi,
est-ce que je peux me contenter
de seulement les opérer,
leur retirer une partie du corps ?
Après tout, c'est mon travail.
Eh bien non, je veux
leur proposer autre chose.
Pour l'après.
Pour ne pas les laisser seuls
avec leur douleur.
Quelque chose de presque magique.
La deuxième raison
de soigner ces patients,
c’est la perte fonctionnelle du membre.
Il faut s’accrocher lors des consultations
pour écouter leurs histoires.
Les accidents d’électrisation,
les accidents domestiques,
les accidents de voiture, les accidents
de la route, principalement.
Mettez-vous à la place du patient
qui se réveille juste
après le bloc opératoire,
juste après l'accident.
Les témoignages sont bouleversants
et stupéfiants.
Là, seuls dans leur lit d’hôpital,
en soulevant leur drap,
ils réalisent l’inimaginable.
Une partie de soi a disparu.
Et l’esprit sera toujours là
pour leur rappeler.
Le défi est alors immense
pour ces patients qui désirent bénéficier
de ce projet bionique.
Ils doivent revivre un passage
au bloc opératoire.
Et cette rééducation longue et assidue
qui ne pardonne pas les écarts.
Lorsque je prends la responsabilité
de soigner ces patients,
je sais que je dois faire un peu plus
que pour mes patients de tous les jours.
Je dois les aider
jusqu’au bout dans leur reconstruction
physique et psychologique.
Ils aspirent à retrouver leur liberté,
leur indépendance, leur dignité
et surtout une place
dans le monde d’aujourd’hui.
Qui pourrait leur refuser
une telle demande ?
Pas moi, pas mon équipe,
et peut-être même pas vous.
Et si certains ici se demandent
si ce petit bijou de technologie
qui vaut si cher pour si peu de personnes,
vaut bien le coup,
à ceux-là, je leur dis :
« Oui, bien sûr que oui. »
Même pour une seule personne.
Je me rappellerai toute ma vie
de ce témoignage de Priscille
à la fin de sa rééducation.
Elle m’a dit :
« Grâce à cette nouvelle prothèse,
je peux tout simplement accompagner
dignement ma fille à l’école.
Car avec cette prothèse,
je peux tenir son cartable
et avec l’autre la tenir par la main.
Je peux reprendre
mes pinceaux et ma peinture
mise de côté depuis dix ans. »
Est-ce que vous imaginez la puissance
de la technologie au service de l’humain ?
C'est une technologie pour réparer
le corps et l'esprit.
Et j’espère que dans quelques années,
Priscille et les autres
pourront également ressentir
au bout de leurs doigts bioniques.
Vous imaginez, pouvoir bouger
presque comme nous ?
Et également sentir
le visage de quelqu’un,
les textures au bout de ses doigts.
La recherche continue.
Notre regard sur le handicap
doit changer et il change, heureusement.
Le monde évolue.
Ce qui terrifiait avant
devient fascinant maintenant.
Avant, la prothèse était cachée.
C’était un honteux prolongement
de soi-même,
presque inerte.
Maintenant, la prothèse
est presque vivante.
Elle est magnifiée, elle est embellie,
Elle est même manucurée.
Vous pouvez même manucurer
les ongles de certaines prothèses
pour mieux les porter tous les jours.
Je dis souvent à mes patients
qui finissent leur projet de soins
et qui se vêtissent
de cette nouvelle prothèse :
« Sortez découvert !
N'ayez plus peur.
Dévoilez au monde qui vous entoure
le pouvoir de cette intelligence
artificielle.
Et surtout de ce travail de renouveau.
Oui, soyez fier de cette reconstruction
et de ce combat mené contre vous-même. »
Et ce combat, je le mène
également tous les jours
pour que demain, un maximum
de nos patients puissent bénéficier
de ces technologies.
Cette première épopée bionique a rendu
mon équipe et moi-même si fiers.
Sûrement l'un des plus beaux cadeaux
de ma carrière professionnelle.
Mon travail, ce n’est pas
que technicité et rationalité.
Non, c'est bien plus que ça.
C’est avoir la chance de contempler
un instant l’essence même de l’humain
dans sa chair et dans son esprit.
Et c'est exactement ça que je retrouve
lors de ces journées de surf avec eux.
Lorsque les soins sont mis
entre parenthèses,
que les belles blouses blanches
repassées sont rangées au placard,
que l’on sort la wax, le néoprène.
Alors là, à ce moment-là,
les masques tombent vraiment.
Et quand je me mets au bord de l’eau
et que je vois Maël et tous les autres
si fiers, si heureux,
glisser sur leur planche,
je les entends aussi me dire :
« Regarde-moi !
Je ne suis plus un malade qui boîte.
Je ne suis plus
une silhouette qui se cache.
Je suis un homme au grand jour,
comme toi. »
Et comme vous tous ici.
Je vous remercie.
(Applaudissements)